hey everybody long time no see I am
Phillip Molina and I've been a little
bit under the weather so thank you to
Eric for covering he did a great job
it will probably see him around more so
don't worry if you love his soothing
chocolatey voice but I am back with a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 6
episode 7 the broken man and with Jon
Snow's resurrection and benjin's return
and now this surprise return to the
Hound this is definitely the comeback
season
speaking of hounds - I should give you a
really quick introduction to the newest
member of the new rockstars team this
Kyle oh hey hi Kyle oh hello yes he is
named after kylo Ren and yes I do expect
him to murder me at some point uh but
for now I should put him down because he
has a lot of editing to do let's keep
going in Oh heads up by the way this
breakdown is gonna have a couple of very
huge theories but I will let you know
when they're coming in case you don't
like theories but alright let's get into
what you're here for the breakdown so
we'll start as usual with a closer look
at the opening images and actually the
episode does something really rare it
splits up the opening images into two
parts so the show pulled this cold open
move in order to hide Rory McCann's name
from the opening credits and that way we
got to get a big ol surprise when we saw
this lovable face return but the opening
image itself is actually this piece of
iron being hammered into a new form
beating it into a new shape that's very
purposeful as this reshaping of men is a
recurring theme of this episode and
Brad's reappears and poet from the 1600s
she once wrote this about beating iron
on an anvil iron til it be thoroughly
heated it's incapable to be wrought so
God sees good to cast some men into the
furnace of affliction and then beats
them on his anvil into what frame he
pleases I'll paraphrase that as iron
can't be shaped until it's been heated
and that's what God does with men he
heats them up with suffering and he
beats the crap out of them until they're
better dudes
so this nail being formed is a broken
man taking a new shape and the Hound was
literally broken when he left him last
and now he's being reformed into
something useful and constructive for
society and what are they constructing
that's a set okay a church for the new
guards and a little missable detail here
the seven beams make
is a heptagon just like the Septon
King's Landing all references to the
seven phases of the new gods and the
seven pointed star
oh also in the books there's always been
this theory about this gravedigger that
Bree and stumbles upon a lot of people
think that guy is the Hound in hiding
and it's interesting to the show chose
to portray the hounds new identity as a
man doing the opposite of that negative
religious image putting corpses down
into the ground he's building up a
church and supporting the people around
him he decided to flip it also before we
leave these opening images the show
keeps returning to this shot of this ax
it's a dual purpose item it's a weapon
that the old hound would have used to
kill and here he's using it as a tool to
help rebuild a similar shot comes back
at the end but for a different reason
oh and really good for those of you who
wondering about my thoughts on
cleganebowl a fight between the mountain
in the Hound hell yes I want it to
happen and you are totally alright the
trial by combat could be a good place
for it but a huge hound sighs but I
don't think either of those things are
going to happen as we expect them to I
don't think the trial by combat is gonna
go according to plan so she's been like
hyping it up way too much all season it
will be a child by combat and I also
think that they're gonna save a hound
Mountain fight for next season probably
since we're kind of running out of time
for big stuff like that's happened this
season and the last thing I'm gonna call
out here is this funny forced
perspective shot that they use to try to
make the Hound seem so huge it's like
how they made the hobbits seem small
next to Gandalf it's supposed to seem
like the Hound and brother ray are
sitting close to each other and the
Hound is just this massive beast
there's a reason I'm a big [ __ ] on
them tough to kill but you can see the
illusion is broken for a moment when ray
stands up and to change angles and he
almost looks bigger than the Hound I do
appreciate the effort though it's a good
way to save money now let's go over to
King's Landing where we find Margaery
reading from the book of the mother and
I think it's kind of funny that Margaery
was already reading exactly the part
about a woman's duties which is what the
high Sparrow wants to talk to her about
her banging Tommen the King mentioned
that since your reunion you haven't
joined him in the marriage bed and Erik
mentioned this before but doesn't it
feel like she's doing a little too well
in this religious transformation slash
brainwash
I mean look at her outfit compared to
what she normally would wear but her
knee keynote to the Queen of thorns
later confirms hey no worries I'm still
a Tyrell look at the Rose and I'm
definitely up to something oh and if
you're a big fan of that role of a wife
is to serve and moan and whatnot you
might like that poet I mentioned earlier
and bradstreet her other stuff all
sounds like that it's women got to be
cooking and whatnot
I will remind you though she was a
Puritan from the 1600s I don't know if
that would fly today as much probably
not now if instead you're kind of
creeped out by the high Sparrow being
super like weirdly wing man e4 Amon and
you're also wondering why he wants her
to have a baby so badly two reasons one
because Tom and Marjorie appear to
belong to the faith now so the Sparrow
is treating the faith itself as if it's
a noble house of its own and it's
sitting on the throne right now but has
no heir if Tommen for to die that level
of influence is something that he's
trying to guarantee for generations to
come but also to the other reason it's
important for there to be an heir this
barrel knows that if Tommen doesn't
produce an heir soon and he dies game
over there is no solid claim to the
throne at that point there are no more
publicly known Baratheon heirs
gendry's still rowing somewhere and so
the Tourelles would try to claim
Margaery gets to be queen
and you know Cersei would be like hell
no and so then we've got a Tyrell
Lannister war and that wouldn't be good
for anybody except if that's true then
why wouldn't Margaery want an heir well
same reason that I said earlier if
Tommen goes down her family and their
massive army will say that she should be
queen and if she has a baby he actually
would outrank her that's kind of messed
up thinking but uh speaking of messed up
thinking that is a lot like that
situation let's activate theory time and
talk about Cersei
skip to this time if you want to avoid
theory time by the way for those of you
that are sticking with us spoiler
warning uh in case this turns out to be
true here's what I think lady Lannister
has planned you know how she's been
going all like crazy the season hugging
that strings and having like no emotion
I'm pretty sure Cersei is a hundred
percent convinced that the prophecy is
gonna keep coming true and Tommen is
going to die soon and I think she's
pretty much already mourned him in her
own way and that's why she's so cold to
him these days he's already dead to her
so then let's just go ahead and assume
Tom and his dead somehow because that's
what Cersei is assuming and so like I
said earlier there'd be no clear
successor the Tyrells would argue that
Margaery should be put in charge as
Queen and they'd have a decent argument
but more than that they have a huge army
that could force it to happen so here's
the main part of this theory I think no
Cersei is not planning to kill Tommen
but she is pretty sure he's gonna die so
she is plotting to kill Margaery and as
many Terrell's as she can with her you
gonna killed him all by himself I think
we were seeing a taste of that plot in
the plan to stop Marjorie's walk of
shame
Jaime might even have been planning to
kill Margaery for her in all the chaos
that was supposed to happen which would
explain why Jaime was even there
he didn't need to be so if Tom and dies
and Margaery and other Terrell's died
then there isn't really any one left to
contest Cersei saying hey you know what
I was the most recent Queen and the
Queen Regent so I have the most valid
claim boom she's queen of Westeros
ruling on her own like she's always
wanted and if you're wondering how this
happens I do really like the theory that
Eric brought up in the last video about
the Wildfire under King's Landing and I
don't know if Eric remembered but that's
definitely the kind of thing that is
always on Circe's mind check it out I
would do anything for you I would burn
cities to the ground I will burn our
house to the ground before I let that
happen she I will burn their cities to
the ground if they touch her and one
last reason why I think this is gonna
happen remember that vision that
Daenerys had way back when in the house
of the undying we all thought it was her
getting a look at King's Landing after
her dragons have
add their way with it but what if it's
actually what the throne room looks like
after Circe's plan has come to fruition
it it'd be kind of ironic for the queen
of fire to have had nothing to do with
this fire check out our last video that
Eric hosted where he goes into some more
detail about what sir ceasefire plan
could be but let's move on okay and if
you just listen to that theory time then
you know that I think Cersei is up to
something here with this conversation
with the Queen of thorns at least more
than she's letting on one reason I think
Cersei is not being totally truthful
here when she asked for this alliance
with the Tourelles
and I'm just write them together we need
each other she's overdoing it and I
think on purpose she comes pleading it
she doesn't snap back and Lady Allah and
all that sass she's giving her she
instead tries to appear humble resting
her hands on that chair of flowers that
represents a Tourelles and much more
obviously she's dressed in the same blue
and gold colors that both Margaery and
lady Tyrell have been wearing rather
than her Lannister red or her mourning
black if you've ever seen the movie
single white female you know not to
trust people when they start dressing
like you gotta be kidding
also though this same imagery gives a
way that this might be false she grips
the chair rather than sitting in it to
be at all's level and then those
matching colors there interestingly
inverted from Mona's look Cersei is
wrapped in blue with golden trim and a
plunging golden chest and she's topped
with her famous Lannister golden hair
the Queen of thorns meanwhile is the
exact opposite wrapped in gold and the
blue plunges into her chest and tops her
head interesting choices by the constant
department that I think are on purpose
it's also interesting that this is
immediately after that really quick Jon
Snow recruitment scenes since they both
are asking for the same thing let's join
our people together to deal with the
larger threat I think these scenes were
purposely placed back-to-back because
visually they're both dominated by the
colors of blue and gold but also listen
closely to that last lion that was
spoken by tormund that perfectly sets up
this Cersei and Queen of thorns scene it
looks clever like you're southerners so
again these back-to-back scenes are
parallel but you can trust the agreement
made in one of them and you should
assume that the
other that takes place deep in the south
the land of the Southerners there's some
clever ulterior motive at play all right
let's move on
ah River Run long time no see also brawn
long time no see he also add myrrh and
black fish you get it so Jaime and Bronn
come upon the weak ass for a siege on
Riverrun and it's funny just how much
better at all this stuff the blackfish
is and not only better than the phrase
he's actually better than Jamie at this
he's totally right that Jamie's army
would starve before they could take the
castle it's 8,000 men but that's 8,000
mouths to feed and considering that the
Tully's have got all the food and
supplies from the area stored inside
these walls yeah they're gonna get
hungry and also this really cool moat
that's another great Riverrun feature
this castle was actually built on the
red fork of the Trident and the
tumblestone River and it has these flood
gates that it can open which it has here
which turns the castle into an island
that's pretty damn hard to attack now
there's not too much else to say here
except that it's cool to see some growth
in Jamie when he demands that Ed Murr be
cleaned and fed which makes sense since
he looks a lot like Jamie did back when
he was a prisoner of war for a long time
also you gotta love the gold hand back
hand so give it rum that's at least one
good reason to have a metal hand oh and
quick observation about the practicality
of the blackfish Jamie's house sigil is
a lion and you can see it all over his
Lannister armor meanwhile the Tully
sigil is a fish and instead of rocking a
bunch of like ornate fish heads sticking
out of his shoulders the blackfish
acknowledges this by covering himself in
bitch-like scale armor that is actually
great protection from piercing and blunt
force attacks so when you compare these
two it's just a reminder that the
blackfish kind of likes his family but
mostly he's a tactical genius and the
Lannisters they're just like a group
Alliance which is called a pride that's
what they're obsessed with their
Lannister pride
moving on to bear island and the
littlest most ferocious bear since Kyle
oh who choose me up beyond belief Lady
Lyanna Mormont
though not stark this is actually the
girl who sent that letter supporting the
starts to Stannis and now seeing that
she's adorable and ten years old that
makes that letter so much more badass
and brave to send to this so-called king
and considering that this is the
house that has produced other badasses
and brave warriors there's definitely
got to be something in the water around
Bear Island in fact I actually don't
think she's totally wrong when she says
every month a bear island fights for the
strength of ten mainlanders her mom was
actually considered one of the best
warriors around they called her she bear
which is only a good nickname in
Westeros and not in real life
it's actually even hinted that she might
have been a better fighter than Brienne
though she's dead now so we'll probably
never see that pay-per-view event in
fact a bunch of this family mostly
female warriors actually were killed at
the red wedding now quickly before we
move on I'll point out that Davos being
the saving grace of this conversation
and being able to connect with Liana
here it's a nice payoff to all these
years of practice he's had with Shireen
that relationship led to this moment
being a successful one and potentially
in a girl in the success of the star
campaign though I still think Davos is
gonna freaking flip when he figures out
how Shireen story ended and I think that
could happen very soon but I will
explain why later
jumping over to their next attempt at
gaining support Jon and company meet
with house Glover and get a pretty hard
no just to connect some dots for
everyone this is Deepwood Motte which is
the place that was until recently under
the control of house Greyjoy and also
the place that Yara just had to run away
from when she lost control if that's
what you're on is talking smack about
her for now in the show it was the
Bolton's that helped the Glovers take
back the castle we've only just taken
back this castle from the Ironborn the
Bolton's helped us do it but in the
books it's actually Stannis and he takes
Yara hostage though she's called OSHA in
the books but speaking of Yara that's an
example of how different her story is
from in the books and I'm pretty sure
yarr is actually gonna get a whole
different plot involving Daenerys the
scene at volantis which is that place
with the bridge that Tyrion was captured
by Jorah a while back it went out of its
way to point out that yar as either
bisexual or a lesbian and while that may
just be a choice made to set the
character apart a friend of mine was
making a totally crude joke that I think
actually could maybe play out here what
if yara has the same plan as you're on
when she gets to marine what if she
thinks that she can seduce Daenerys I
know that sounds like nerdy pervy fan
fiction but in the
books Daenerys is actually super
bisexual like she hooks up with ladies
all the time that she treats it like
therapy for her so I'm just saying it
could happen now before we leave this
scene though I'd like to point out that
this is where we realize that there
isn't just one broken man you're a flat
out refers to Theon as broken you're so
broken there's no coming back and just
like the hounds arc in this episode
Fionna and this one scene is called
broken and insulted he's made fun of for
having no dick and told he should kill
himself which makes me think that Yara
would fit right in with youtube comment
trolls but then as he takes that beating
the suffering that is the heat that anne
bradstreet told us about he's being
reformed and hardened and he's becoming
a new man he's not reek anymore but he's
also not exactly Theon Greyjoy because
that guy is kind of a dick this broken
man has been reformed and just something
new and we don't know what it is yet
we've never seen it but I'm very curious
to see what role he's gonna play in
these talks in Mereen now moving on to
Jon's campground it was hard to catch
but Davos reminds us that this is where
Stannis was camped before they marched
on Winterfell and that's significant for
two reasons one it's not somewhere you
can stay long Stannis lost a lot of men
in this place who died or abandoned him
which explains why Jon says they can't
wait any longer to march on Winterfell
and to that's the camp where Shireen was
burned and like I said earlier if Davos
realizes that somehow well then I think
he's gonna be a lot less cheery and yes
I know he's not at all cheery that is my
point
he's gonna flip out and I'm just gonna
be like I'm not also I got to point out
what a little badass Lyanna Mormont is
did you see her she's there at the
campsite is she gonna march on
Winterfell too what if she takes on
Ramsay she'd probably kill him she's the
most adorable little murderer and I just
loved it at Sansa rights it's pretty
obvious what's going on there right
she's writing to Littlefinger to bring
the knight to the Vale to help John and
his army if it helps you can put the
thing down flip it and reverse it and
then hit enhance you can't read it
perfectly but it says something like now
you have a chance to fulfill your
promise or something the Knights of the
Vale are under your command right for
Winterfell
give us your aid and I shall see that
you are rewarded ki T don't ever change
have a great summer Sansa Stark now
again I don't
fault John for being like we got a move
but also it makes sense that Santa wants
more help I do think she needs to trust
her team a bit more and let them in on
this tactical advantage they totally
could have but whatever what I don't
care whatever gets that huge army to
help wipe out Ramsay snow I'm all for
now moving on we get a sermon from
brother ray and I'm pretty sure that
this is kind of a replacement for this
really famous speech in the books
brother ray talks about having been a
soldier and having been given orders to
murder steal and pillage and how he came
to forget his own good nature now he's
talking about himself here but in the
books there's a similar speech and
actually is about the generic broken man
and the point isn't just a connection to
our episode's theme about how broken men
can be reformed like iron into something
new but it's also actually about the
whole show the whole book series the
entirety of Game of Thrones because it's
important to note that both speeches are
actually about soldiers being given
orders and in the book that actually
gets really into how the soldier starts
out as a simple man maybe a farmer and
by the end he's this violent brute who
pillages people like simple farmers and
the point there is that this game of
thrones they're really only a few people
play like what like maybe a dozen people
are playing it it actually poisons all
men men who could not care less about
who sits on the throne they too are
broken down and turned into villains the
point is even if they don't care at all
no one gets to stay good in this world
and that sucks but that's also a good
segue to these three riders who are from
the Brotherhood without banners because
here's what's weird about these guys
when we last encountered this group they
were led by beric Dondarrion and that
guy Thoreau sub Mir kept bringing beric
back because barrack was doing the
Lord's work
barracks basically Robin Hood and in
fact that whole group was created in
response to the armies that kept
ravaging the common folk of the
Riverlands
so they sounded like not too bad of guys
and yet here they are now maybe no
longer led by barrack and they're the
murderers and they themselves are the
ones ravaging the common folk of the
Riverlands no matter how you started no
one gets to say good in this world
I've actually got another theory about
what is going on with these guys and why
they're different now but I will save
that for when we go over next week's
episode but don't worry because I've got
totally crazy theory
stuff coming up right now ish so we go
to Braavos and Arya's booking passage to
Westeros and really quick I'm going to
point out a miserable line here before
Ari approaches a westerosi captain he
says to the other guy that he's heard
Indian sweets this language bling we saw
those huge Greyjoy sigils on the sails
of yarn Theon ships which were in
volantis very recently but Yara said
they were leaving soon so if they are
already in slavers Bay then they're
gonna be in marine crazy soon like
they're basically already there also I
don't think it would be Euron's thousand
ships yet because they're probably still
making those but anyway Arya decides to
get some last minute sightseeing in for
some reason in yada-yada she gets waved
and you already know what happened there
but let's talk about some other
possibilities of what could have
happened there and two things one
there's a lot of theory coming with that
could always be spoilers so jump ahead
to this time if you want to skip them
but - these aren't regular theories this
is really out there stuff so I'll still
say that what happened here was probably
just exactly what we saw Arya was caught
off guard by the waif and is now
fighting to survive but let's activate
really out there theory time
okay plugins sound a little crazy but
are you ready what if this is all part
of arias plan or if not arias maybe jock
ins plan either way it feels like there
might be more going on here let's start
with the last time we saw Aria behaving
normally she had just decided she was a
stark after all she retrieves needle and
she goes into hiding in that complete
darkness and you can see she's acting
very paranoid when we see her next she's
without needle and her demeanor just
feels a bit off her posture her hands
behind her back her clothes it all feels
weird
so one thing at a time her physicality
well ever since season one they've made
sure to point out to us that aria is
left-handed the actress has even
discussed that she has trouble with this
because she herself is right-handed so
it does stand out a little that
throughout this sequence chooses her
right hand as her dominant hand she
tosses the bags with it she picks them
up again she clutches her wounds with
the right hand and those clothes they
are definitely a very different outfit
than we last saw her and in fact she
walks by someone dressed exactly like
Aria was recently dressed could that be
the real Aria or is it maybe who are you
based her look off of and this is just a
small hint to remind us that this person
here now might not be the real Aria but
someone in an Aria disguise maybe this
is a person who would demand a cabin at
lunch cabin believe it don't when the
real Aria has exactly stated that she
doesn't care about cabins I wouldn't
need a cabin and then remember how we
last saw her extremely cautious guarded
ready for a fight and now when this old
woman approaches she's totally clueless
and welcoming look at that face Aria has
never been more happy go-lucky in her
entire life so maybe could it be that
she actually recognizes this old woman's
face maybe because she specifically was
looking at that exact face in the house
of black and white the last time she was
examining the faces so maybe this face
actually means oh there's my assassin
great everything is going according to
plan and what plan would that be well I
see two options one is that it's a plan
to bring the wave to somewhere that Aria
can actually win in a one-on-one fight
notice how Aria doesn't actually ask any
one for help if the wave follows these
drops of blood and continues to track
Aria it's very likely she will find
herself maybe an artist a little hideout
where we know she's probably left needle
and where it gets pitch-black fighting
the waif without any vision it's exactly
what Aria has trained to do thus she
would have the upper hand there or the
other point of this plan could be a test
for the weight and that test would be
administered by Professor jock and agar
because if we examine his last scene
with the wave she's made it clear to her
teacher that she is no longer behaving
like a faceless man the waif actually
refers to herself
twice in first-person pronouns she
doesn't say a girl or a [ __ ] but rather
this way as I expected you promised me
look at jock in space here that's
definitely disappointment but it comes
after the weight says you promised me
it's the weight that he's disappointed
in so when he says shame we kissed
who's to say he's not referring to the
waif here especially considering he
specifically told away not to let Aria
suffer and obviously her attack was
meant to make her suffer she could have
easily done a throat slash instead she
does a dozen stabs and then the show
makes a point of showing she even twist
the knife so in this scenario would be
jock in who's administering this test
and it could even be him who's
pretending to be Aria in this moment we
have seen him wear her face before and I
know that would let himself get stabbed
and potentially killed but if you
remember Aria didn't name a jock in
himself as the third man she wanted dead
calf leg off
hey go gives a man his own name that's
right uh name me no please and even
though they have some debate about it
she never technically unnamed him so
maybe he's fine with being killed and as
part of this test but you want to get
even weirder okay it could also be
serial Pharrell that is wearing her face
in this moment do you remember him are
his old sword fighting teacher we never
actually saw him die and he is from
Braavos where this is all taking place
right now and in fact he was the first
sword of Braavos so he was like super
legit over here so he easily could have
been maybe one of the faceless men and
when he speaks up the god of death back
then what do we
to the god of death not today go so he
could still be alive and kicking
also that god of death that he speaks of
is who aria has been serving in the
house of black and white and speaking of
the house the actor that plays Syrio
Forel was asked if his character's
familiar with it and he messed up and
said that serial is very familiar with
the house a black and white relationship
well yeah what no no oh yes I do the
weird theories and there because this is
really out there theory time and you can
get stuck in here forever
maybe Aria isn't even working alone in
this maybe she got even more help maybe
it could be this boy who is the only one
wearing blue in this scene so he stands
out who walks past her and she almost
bumps into him maybe there's some sort
of handoff or something and then after
she passes him and he takes a moment he
turns around and walks faster than
everyone else to catch up and keep
following her and maybe that's also him
in the promo for next week when it looks
like aria is taking that leap there in
the window so maybe he's in on it or
maybe he's a spy for somebody else so ok
those are all the crazy possibilities
now let's acknowledge why they could be
totally wrong Aria might be acting
differently because she has finally reom
braced being a stark of Winterfell a
girl of noble birth and now she just
walks as such she's definitely
left-handed most of the time but there
have been other times where she uses her
right hand and those weren't Impostors
that we know of and maybe she's wearing
different clothes because she just no
longer is wearing that old disguise and
maybe she would have wanted a cabin now
but the other time she was trying to get
to Braavos anywhere she could and she
was trying to show she was desperate and
willing to compromise and maybe she
really did just let her guard down and
her plan would have been really dumb if
the wave had just slit her throat and
maybe jockin never did use arias space
and she was just hallucinating that
because it was from the potion that made
her blind and maybe that boy is just an
extra that they reused in a bunch of
different shots just like I did in my
college films because I could not afford
enough extras and maybe the Syrio Forel
actor just messed up okay so that pretty
much covers everything so are you super
confused now good me too
haha but if you're wondering where I
really stand on this I guess
yes something is going on here that we
don't know I don't think it's super
complicated but I do think that Aria may
have been expecting this and has some
sort of plan or fine one last theory
maybe the waif isn't real maybe she was
never real maybe she's the no one that
lives inside of art his head and it's
who Aria is supposed to be and maybe
every scene that's been with a wave has
actually been a scene with Aria and it
would explain why nobody but Jockin or
aria ever even acknowledges the way even
when she's openly beating a blind beggar
in the middle of town and if yes this
would be totally insane but it totally
could be real is this messing you up now
yeah let that haunt your dreams for a
while how about we get out of really out
there theory time and back to normal
mode okay
kylo farted he got confused that was a
very crazy one but if you didn't watch
that daytime just now good on you but
also if you want to still find some
interesting stuff going on in the scene
I'll point out two things about it first
this one was tweeted at me by at Luke
David Sims he cut together a short
montage with this re-attack scene and
other moments and just like when the
wave hits Aria a few episodes back in
ways that represent each of the injuries
her siblings have received it continues
here with are you experiencing the
slashes gut stabs and near drownings
that the rest of the stark clan has
dealt with so good find Luke and then
for the second observation I just need
to jump ahead to the final scene of the
episode and the closing images once the
Hound discovers what the Brotherhood has
done he strolls through the bodies he
sees brother ray hanging out and he
launches on a journey to seek vengeance
and this scene is purposely side by side
with Aria scenes so that we can feel
some parallels to their situations we
have these wide shots and these
close-ups of staggering through the
crowd but their circumstances are
actually inverses of each other
Aria is the only wounded one amongst the
crowd while the Hound is the only one
unscathed there was a time when the
Hound had suffered stab wounds and took
a big fall and then was left for dead
and Aria left to seek vengeance
now it's Aria with the stab wounds and
the fall and the Hound on his road to
vengeance it's just funny how these very
different characters have always been
cosmically linked and then in the
closing shot of the episode where we
linked to the opening act shots where
the axe was swung in as a tool and it's
now being pulled out as a weapon that's
also the thing with broken
and also with iron in general Theon is
totally broken and he's trying to
rebuild and come back as a more nobleman
and Arya Stark even has broken down her
upbringing she's broken down right now
and she's being reformed into an
assassin and even Jon Snow was broken by
the watch and remade into possibly the
Lord of Winterfell or who knows maybe
even king of the north but when it comes
to Sandor Clegane at least as far as
he's concerned just because he went into
the fires as a weapon this hammering
he's been suffering this pounding it
doesn't mean he's gonna come out as some
noble tool like brother Rey wanted him
to he might not become that useful nail
from the beginning the broken man might
just be reformed as a new kind of weapon
different yeah but still deadly and
killing might just always be what he
does best and there might actually not
even be anything wrong with that because
you could just as easily pound that same
melted iron into a pretty badass
axe all right onto a next week's episode
it's called no one so that definitely
sounds like it's gonna give us a lot of
answers about what's going on with that
Aria situation let's watch the preview
do your man to step aside or there will
be violence
I just find it
okay so Searcy is choosing violence
which are the badass fine but again that
makes him feel like yeah trial by combat
is probably not happening they're
probably just like ambushing the faith
instead I think Lancel is as good as
dead
also in this episode the Queen of thorns
said about septa unella she could use a
good bashing I feel like with this that
has to be foreshadowing and I would love
that so much to see septa unella just
smushed let's keep going
should I fail to persuade the blackfish
to surrender and if you which have to
cast honor compels me to fight you okay
so Breen and Jamie so then yeah this is
what I was gonna mention about the
Brotherhood earlier in that section in
the books
the Brotherhood actually does get a new
leader and this new leader is way more
vicious than beric Dondarrion and Breen
and Jamie who are currently in the
Riverlands they encounter this new
leader in the books kind of around this
time the thing about this new leader is
that everyone has said that that person
is never gonna appear on the show
because it's a huge deal it's very crazy
and I I don't even want to talk about it
too much because it'd be a big spoiler
but is there ever gonna bring this
person in and which would be insane now
is the time to do it when Breen and
Jamie are in the Riverlands and the
Brotherhood is randomly back and there's
suddenly bad guys I love Suzy if I have
to slaughter every Tully you ever lived
to get back to her
that's probably
okay a lot of stuff was going on there
the waste is probably chasing someone
probably this Li Peoria but look at the
wave space it kind of looks like she was
caught off guard doesn't she like maybe
there's just a dinner
sneak attack or something I very much
hope so also the Hound swings an axe at
a guy um so yeah he's definitely gonna
go after the Brotherhood I think and at
least kill some of them uh or hey at the
most maybe he'd even become their their
new leader that'd be interesting but
also if their old leader beric
Dondarrion isn't there when he gets her
that would again leave a perfect spot
open for a different leader so it could
be that other person keep an eye out for
that also somebody like Chuck's Podrick
or something but he's probably like
smiling I feel like this is might be an
editing trick this isn't a battle this
is there's something else going on there
and then tyrion is staring up this
candelabra and it is it like shaking
maybe if so marine under attack or are
the dragons doing something um I don't
know it could also have something to do
with maybe Theon and Yara they should be
right there if they're in slavers Bay
and yeah yeah and then the mountain is
clearly gonna take off this guy's head
uh which is again further proof I don't
think the trial by combat is gonna
actually happen um which is cool in one
way because it means the faith might
feel some of that Circe wrath sooner
rather than later but what's not cool is
that it shoots down a lot of those
theories that people have that Sandor
and Gregor we're gonna fight in that
trial by combat so if this is true and
it's not gonna happen
then that fight again yeah it's probably
not happening this season let's get on
to our questions that I have for you
guys one is the hound a good guy now
he's definitely about to seek out his
vengeance but so is Arya maybe I mean he
could be a good guy now what do you
think - what the hell is going on with
Arya if you want to know all those crazy
theories go back and watch that really
out there theory time but there's
something going on there I think more
than what meets the eye so tell me what
you think in the comments and three does
Cersei have a secret plan that she's in
the middle of and does she think that
Tommen is as good as their because it
would totally motivate her to do some
crazy stuff and that's it this guy has
been
very good sleeping at my feet this whole
time so he's gonna do the outro with us
I made sure to subscribe to new rock
stars because we do videos like this all
the time but also share this video if
you like this kind of stuff we've been
doing the whole season it's all very
interesting I think to share with your
Game of Thrones fan friends uh also if
you have any questions for me hit me up
on Twitter at fimo it's a little short
on Twitter so you can't always ask
in-depth stuff so if you have a larger
theory or concept you can hit me up on
facebook at facebook.com/ slash fimo
knows and also follow at new rock stars
because that's where we post when these
videos come out so send all your
questions about when the videos come out
- at new rock stars on Twitter not me I
don't know what else this episode was
kind of short by the way but the next
three episodes are all kind of long and
they get longer as they go so I'm so
pumped I feel like they're starting the
season finale like next week and it's
just gonna last three episodes in a way
I think it's gonna get crazy episode 9
it's always freaking crazy so I'm really
excited for that I think we're gonna see
the battle between the Bolton's
and the Starks and that's so exciting
but that's it I guess hit me up on those
places I talked about if anything I'll
see you next time bye